we have a voicemail line that number is
two one nine two david p i'm gonna admit
it upfront this is a very ugly voicemail
about george Floyd or George florid as
this caller says just so we get out of
our echo chamber this is an example of
the perspective that some Americans have
about George Floyd take a look yes I
just don't think that the public needs
to be advised that George florid has a
long criminal record she also had drugs
in his system so you know what is the
big deal here thank you for your time
what difference does it make whether or
not George Floyd had drugs in his system
we have the confrontation on video we
know what happened we know about 8
minutes and 46 seconds of kneeling on
George Floyd's neck being on drugs
doesn't mean if police kill you it's
justified being on drugs doesn't mean
it's just a fight or that you deserve to
be shot or or in any other way hurt by
police this is very dangerous thinking
and unfortunately it is not as rare as
people like me who live in a blue state
might think this stuff is dangerously
common this stuff explains how Trump
still has you know 39% approval right so
let's not forget that and let's make
sure that we take care of business in
November because these folks vote very
very ugly ugly voicemail we have a great
bonus show coming up for you today and I
also want to remind you tonight we are
playing chess it is the second ever
David Pakman show chess tournament 8:00
p.m. Eastern today Tuesday June 16th I
hope you'll join me register for free at
david pakman.com slash chess we'll see
you tonight
or on the bonus show or tomorrow I guess